[Music]
hi and uh thank you so much for coming
to the first parel Society Congress um
you know Dev kzero was you know roughly
30 to 40 people um and it is kind of an
abstract concept for and New Concepts uh
for for many here so uh it's great to
have such a fantastic turnout um so I
guess the intention uh with this event
um from today and uh in in future events
is to bring together the the deepest
thinkers we can find as well as
practitioners in the creation of uh
competitive governance and institutional
design um and I I'll be quite short and
and and to the point I can tend to
Waffle about political philosophy quite
a bit and I'll try to spare you from
that a little um but really uh there's
kind
of two on one hand this is a fantastic
opportunity that I leevers are coming to
us um for the reasons uh outlined in uh
by the World Bank in a 2006 report
called where is the world uh where is
the wealth of uh Nations uh and in that
report um they discovered that actually
uh in almost every country it was rule
of law institutions that were the
largest contributors to wealth for those
countries even Beyond natural resource
extraction um and this
coupled with uh what we know from
institutional economics that uh a mere
0.1% production and transaction costs
can enable a country to quadruple its
wealth this is the difference between
Switzerland and
Argentina this means for me at least
that there is a huge opportunity uh
ahead of us that could be potentially
worth trillions of dollars of value and
increase the quality of life of humans
and live many millions out of poverty
but on the other hand uh a lot has
changed uh certainly uh certainly in OCD
uh countries since the
1950s
um back in the 1950s uh 19 90% of retail
investors held stocks in uh corporations
uh as of 2009 that had dropped down to
2% with institutional uh institutional
investors holding it during that time
you had uh the reduction of civic
participation and Civil Society uh since
the 60s uh it has dropped dramatically
in uh in terms of uh by like roughly 30%
today
um this is complete shift in how our
societies function there aren't the same
kind of Social Clubs Civic partici uh
participations trade unions and so on
this notion of participatory democracy
uh has basically gone uh in sway of
Party politics and uh consumer politics
uh so people tend to have political
ideas intermediated by algorithms on big
platforms
um at the same time uh post 9911 we've
seen the reduction of our civil
liberties uh of freedom of speech of the
right to associate uh new forms of
sensorship as well as atomization of the
the
individual moreover uh
government debt or the debt to GDP
ratios has starting to reach points in
which uh potential uh at least
historically uh those countries have
collapsed uh the national um uh
intelligence Council and the government
accountability office have warned U that
this can enter into a debt spiral in
which it it'll be almost unsustainable
if not difficult to ever recover from uh
this applies not only to the us but all
developed and developing oecd countries
uh and we're likely to see that over the
next two
decades now while these are challenges
they are also opportunities there are
potentials for us to experiment and come
up with new ways of uh offering
Alternatives in governance to create a
sort of startup sector in the Notions of
governance um and so what will be
represented by this event is what those
governance structures will look like to
to start having discussions about what
the future may look like to create a
better world they'll range from
homeowners associations to popup
societies uh to special economic
zones perhaps even entirely new nation
states or Proto States uh furthermore
we're starting to see the rise of uh new
orders uh Sovereign orders enabled by
new technologies such as uh
blockchains um so with that in mind um I
just want to thank you so much uh for
coming uh and I'm looking forward to
building the future with you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]